[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's c
sharp orange two three i see you
caleb cut it go for it
[Laughter]
hang on hang on what are y'all laughing
at so connie got a little lost in it
that's a good thing look i remember one
time my dad took me to this
jazz club and that's the last place i
wanted to be but then i see this guy
and he's playing his chords with force
on it
and then with a minor then he has the
inner voices
and it's like he's it's like he's
singing
and i swear the next thing i know it
it's like he
floats off the stage that guy was lost
in the music he was
in it and he took the rest of us with
him
that's when i knew i was born to play
streaming this christmas on disney plus
look around
life has so much to offer
[Music]
we only have a short time on this planet
[Music]
don't miss out on the joys of life
remember to enjoy every minute of it
[Music]
joey has gotten
[Music]
hey carly leon skipping town really put
us in a bind man
i'll bet glad you made it my boy bishop
said he uh sat in with you on a set last
year in brooklyn
said you were great well you'll have a
for a coffee shop
[Music]
huh
hey arthea this is the cat i was telling
you about
my old middle school band teacher mr
gardner call me joe dorothea uh
i mean uh miss williams said it's a
pleasure wow this is amazing
uh joe is ray gardner son
so we're down to middle school band
teachers now
[Music]
uh sorry i zoned out a little back there
joe gardner where have you been i've
been uh
teaching middle school band but on the
weekends
you got a suit get a suit teach a good
suit
back here tonight first shows at nine
soundchecks at seven
we'll see how you do
[Music]
i did it i got the gig i don't know i
know
dorothea williams can't you believe it
just don't tell my mom about this okay
forget class
i'm in a different class i'm in the
dorothea williams class buddy
[Music]
oh we're gonna get into this now excuse
me
[Music]
stop fighting and have a life
22 has been at the u seminar for quite
some time and has had such notable
mentors as gandhi
abraham lincoln and mother teresa i made
her cry
ignore that we're truly glad to have you
here dr borgensen
[Music]
it is an honor having you prepared 22
for earth
i'm going to make you wish you never
died most people wish that 22.
bye is this heaven
no is it h e double hockey sticks
help help help help
quiet coyote it's easy to get turned
around this isn't the great beyond
it's the great before the great before
oh we call it the you seminar now
[Music]
rebranding
does this mean i'm dead not yet your
body's in a holding pattern
it's complicated i'll get you back to
your group
come on little souls get on up here
welcome to the youth seminar
[Music]
this movie soul celebrates the idea of
community and the people that are around
us
it shines a beautiful artistic light on
what a neighborhood and love for your
neighbor should be
joe's neighborhood formed him in the way
a lot of city kids grow up where it's
not just your immediate family that kind
of raise you you're brought up by
everybody that you come in contact with
in your neighborhood joe's still
stopping by his
mother's tailoring shop and all the
women that work there are like
aunties and surrogate mothers to him you
look mob it fits
perfect there's the barber shop and all
the
locals who are there week to week to
week you can go into that barbershop and
you can talk about
anything from love laughter anger
politics and feel comfortable and it's a
good old-fashioned neighborhood where
everybody knows your name
what i love about what seoul does as a
movie as far as
the way that they present a neighborhood
is you just have a diverse
array of different people people make
the community
and community is important one of the
things that seoul does so well is
celebrate
how important it is to just be a good
member of your community and how some of
the best work you will ever do in your
life has to do with
making the people around yous lives
better
because when you share the load of
living
it makes it easier we really need to
celebrate that being able to celebrate
community
being able to celebrate love this looks
for the good we're showing you the good
of life we're showing you joe's smile
we're showing you joe's energy
and he just wants to pass it on disney
and pixar's soul
starts streaming december 25th disney
and pixar
seoul streaming on disney plus december
25th
music is all i think about
from the moment i wake up in the morning
to the moment i fall asleep at night
i was born to play
it's my reason for living
hello
oh my god
[Music]
there's a soul missing
is this heaven no is it h e
double hockey sticks how how hell quiet
coyote
no it's the great before this is where
new souls get their personalities
quirks and interest before they go to
earth here we are
don't worry you can't crush a soul here
that's what life on earth is for
it's my life can you help me get back
come on
this won't be a disaster that's for sure
you're out these dummy little so
and i'm gonna find you
life is full of possibilities
[Music]
you just need to know where to look
don't miss out on the joys of life
like uh pizza i can't smell
we can't we can't taste either all that
stuff is in your body no smell
no taste or touch see
okay i get it disney and pixar's soul
get ready your life is about to start
start streaming december 25th
bye